على الرغم من مرور ثماني سنوات على انضمام
دوله فلسطين الاتفاقيه القضاء على جميع
اشكال التمييز ضد المراه
الا ان سلطه الفلسطينيه لم تتمكن من
تنفيذه هذه الاتفاقيه على ارض الواقع
بحاله الجدل ورفض العشائر الفلسطينيه
والحركات الاسلاميه لها خاصه بعد
الاحتجاجات العديده المطالبه سلطه
الفلسطينيه بالانسحاب من هيك ونهايه تنتهي
كوشريعه الاسلاميه والاعراف والتقاليد حسب
رايهم احنا لما نيجي نحكي على اتفاقيه
سيدهوف بدنا نلغي المحاكم الشرعيه فاحنا
مش رايحين الجابه بس الشارع اذا طبقناها
بالحيثيات الكامله والجنه بذلك وانما راح
جاب ايضا حتى في رجال الدين التابعين
للمؤسسات الدينيه مثلا همم قاضي القضاه
تحدث في الموضوع قال انه اي نص يخالف
الشرع هو مرفوض
لكن الحركه النسويه التي تتهم السلطه
الفلسطينيه بدعم العشائر والمحاباتي معها
ظلت تنادي بضروره التزام السلطه بما وقعت
عليه والعمل على مواعمه الاتفاقيات
والمعاهدات الدوليه التي انضمت اليها مع
القوانين المحليه لم يتم التوائم مع
الاتفاقيه التي جوهرها بالاساس احقاق
المساواه التامه وعدم التمييز هناك صوت
متنامي في الحركه النسويه ان يجب تغيير
ادوات الضغط على هذه السلطه من اجل احترام
حقوق النساء في المساواه في كافه المحاور
وعمليا الحقول التي يتناولتها الاتفاقيه
الانسانيه الى وجود تقصير من السلطه
الفلسطينيه في توضيح الاتفاقيه واهدافها
فانها اتهمت كذلك جهه لم تسميها في سن
حمله تحرير ضد الاتفاقيه لاستخدام التطبيل
ونشر المعلومات غير صحيحه